hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us let's get it what's
up I'm KFC and this is final burg we've
been doing answer the internet where we
put celebrities to the test with the
most difficult hypothetical questions
the Internet has ever found this is
debate the internet where we'll be
breaking down the most highly contested
questions from ATI today we're breaking
down one of the most disturbing
questions we've ever come across
would you rather your mother or your
daughter be a porn star it's like high
school debate club accept a new
nightmares I'm a father I will be taking
the side that I would much rather have
my mother be a porn star he's an idiot
he'll be taking the side of the daughter
I'm choosing my daughter because I don't
even know if I'm ever gonna have a
daughter
there is no facts for that I have had a
laptop in my lap for 20-plus years I
keep a phone under my dick while I Drive
there's like a really significant chance
I have a zero sperm count I don't even
know if I want kids if I have kids I
might have a son my sperm might be
mutated it might be cancerous I might
have a deformed daughter who is not
welcomed into the pornography world
there's no guarantee I have a daughter
so this is a little loophole choosing
daughter well I am a father and I do
have a daughter a fully functioning one
a non deformed one and I'm here to tell
you and all the fathers know this if you
have a daughter there is no chance you
can answer this question with your
daughter being a porn star it just does
not compute it is not an option
you raise your little girl to be smart
and pretty and nice and kind and you
want to go get a job and break through
the glass ceiling and not suck a dick
for a living man can't have you Chris
Rock once famously said you got to keep
your daughter off the pole I'm here to
say you got to keep your daughter off
the girls do porn set I don't want
anybody at the back room casting couch
looking to make one thousand to five
thousand dollars a day to suck some dick
of a guy with a huge Tommy John's scar
up his elbow okay what's up his leg no
it's definitely his arm it's not as like
the guys the guys got the scar on his
leg it's on his [ __ ] arm
there's one with the big scrub as well
the one I'm talking about he's got a
[ __ ] scar on his arm don't you talk
to me about casting couch that hole
sucking dick comment felt like an
unwarranted attack on all our porn star
friends a Bella gesture roads Phoenix
Marie
fantastic porn stars even better answer
the internet contestants but Kevin is
worried about keeping his daughter off
the pole
I'm worried about keeping me me you see
if I had a mother as a porn star this
guy is a different person this guy was
bullied on the playground this guy wept
in his locker every single day as kids
texted me pictures of my mom sucking
penises having sex with penises that
weren't my dad's all kinds of things
that would just destroy the psyche in my
formative years I'm probably I'm
probably a drug addict I started getting
it right I'll paint you a picture of
what happens to me if my mother's a porn
star I start getting in fights in
elementary school immediately sixth
grade I stabbed a kid with a pencil cuz
he showed me a picture of my mom having
sex by eighth grade I've been suspended
from school more times than I can count
and I don't even know if I want to do
high school I do until sophomore year
before I get into weed and meth and
selling crack and I decide you know what
a GED smore likely down the line I
dropped out of high school join the army
get blown up in Iraq that's what happens
to me ants eating that doesn't exist
you're welcome my mom you're welcome for
not having a mom who's important John's
worried about growing up to be a
well-adjusted man who has a nice
successful happy life well I already
have that and it will all be torn down
if my daughter has sex on camera for a
living every every job I walk into there
goes the guy whose daughter is a literal
[ __ ] every room I walk into at the
cocktail party you go to parent-teacher
night it's like Oh what happened to your
daughter I should [ __ ] guys why are
guys [ __ ] her in the butt for a
living now you've become a complete
failure that nobody can trust nobody can
take seriously and everything that you
built up because your mom wasn't a porn
star is now torn down because your
daughter is a porn star I'm 31 years old
I live on Sour Patch Kids tobacco and
whiskey I am on borrowed time already my
real body age is like I don't know a
hundred and eighty six so if I have a
daughter right now I'm probably dead by
the time she gets her driver's license
there's no chance I'm around for a
daughter who has expanded on a porn
career there's no chance I'm around for
a daughter who's hitting that like I'm a
director now stage of porn if I have a
daughter right now on set by the time I
die
she's hitting like the introductory face
of porn we're like I have to go
searching for her I'm lazy I'm only on
the front page of pornhub I would never
even see her anyway it would never
affect me for a single second and let's
say for the sake of argument let's say
that I become a medical marvel and lived
to fifty five think about what the
future is gonna be like then think about
what's happening in 2038 okay right now
everyone's having sex on camera
teenagers are sex in their penises in
high school locker rooms but it's gonna
be a class saw in college cam soda calm
how to please your viewers I am not
worried it's just gonna be a thing
people do to be like you go to
Thanksgiving you talk about how many
subscribers you have what kind of sugar
daddies are giving you twitter won't
exist that thing's already circling the
drain it's gonna be only fans calm is
the only way anyone has any social media
interaction watch me finger myself today
for nickels so so in fact if I do have a
daughter who goes into porn thank God
because she's one of the popular ones
listen bottom line if you have a
daughter and you'll hold the daughter in
your arms and you raise a daughter she's
just the last person you want to do porn
I don't care who else does point I love
porn otherwise I'll watch anybody else's
porn I will watch my mother's porn if
she decides to do it I will jerk off to
my mother's porn before I let my little
girl dabble in the world of pornography
it's sick and it's wrong and I won't
stand for it unless it's someone else in
which case I would watch it every day
and I will love it I'll be interested in
I'll interact with you you can come on
my show you can do a TI it's great as
long as it's not my daughter thumper
time that was some good spirited debate
yeah I think I won but I'll take
accepted congratulations
I also have to offer condolences on your
future deform daughter so be right and I
I also have to let you know that I was
on pornhub the other day and I and I saw
your mother she she does porn it's like
that's why let us know who you think won
leave a comment below make sure you rate
and subscribe and also make sure you go
get answer the internet the card game
it's available right now on Barstow
Sports Amazon Walmart and you can catch
it at Spencer Gifts if you're still at
the mall buy it play along with us